Boa noite minhas amigas meus amigos para
mais uma live Boa noite Carlos à medida
que vocês for entrando por favor vocês
vão dando também um Olá um boa noite
para poder cumprimentar
vocês muito bem vamos falar de dois
artigos hoje e depois nós vamos
responder à dúvidas de quem estiver com
dúvidas no documento e também as dúvidas
ao
vivo então no vídeo de hoje nós vamos
abordar dois artigos um deles é um
estudo crucial que explora a eficácia da
cor cumina no tratamento de pacientes
hospitalizados com covid 19 de grau leve
a moderado então não vou falar mais essa
palavra para evitar de dar problema no
vídeo Então esse composto natural tem
sido alvo de pesquisa devido a suas
propriedades antiinflamatórias e
antioxidantes que Teoricamente poderiam
ter benefícios naquele vírus que você
sabe qual que é então vamos aprofundar
nos detalhes desse
estudo então nós sabemos que a pandemia
desafiou muito a comunidade médica a
buscar tratamentos eficazes e esse
estudo que nós estamos falando da
curcumina foi realizado no hospital
iraniano chamado ali
asgar no qual foi testada a
curcumina porque ele poderia I
potencialmente ter propriedades
antivirais interessantes então o estudo
analisou 76 participantes sem distúrbios
de coagulação que a cumina pode em
alguns casos eh ser
anticoagulante então esses 76
participantes tinham uma média de idade
de 54 anos o índice de massa corporal
entre 28 e 30 então eles estavam
sobrepeso e obesos né Então essa
pesquisa foi concebida como ensaio
controlado randomizado de duas semanas
dividindo os participantes em dois
grupos um grupo que recebeu cápsulas de
curcumina da marca ca curcumim Sina
curcumim quatro vezes por dia em um
grupo controle então cada cápsula dessa
curcumina conha 40 MG de Nan curcumina
que é uma formulação de nanopartículas
que é projetado para aumentar a
solubilidade e biodisponibilidade boa
noite Cristina então ambos os grupos
receberam esse tratamento padrão paraa
doença pro vírus que incluía uma gama de
Terapias uso de antivirais
anticoagulantes e
vitaminas Então os resultados foram
observados no 144 14º dia indicaram que
o grupo que usou curcumina de alta
absorção teve uma diminuição notável em
sintomas como tosse fadiga em relação ao
grupo controle Além disso se notou que o
grupo de cucumina nitou menos de uso de
máscaras de
oxigênio e apresentou uma melhoria na
taxa respiratória e nos níveis de
saturação de oxigênio então
Eh mas Vale ressaltar que houve
desistências no grupo de curcumina Teve
gente que parou de tomar bem como
relatos de efeitos colaterais como boca
seca náusea urina Amarelo
colorida então para ilustrar a aplicação
prática Dessa descoberta podemos
mencionar outros estudos realizados com
mesmo produto sin curcumim que também
observou melhorias Nas condições
respiratórias do pacientes então Além
disso teve ensaios clínicos que
relataram uma redução no risco de
mortalidade para covid quando o cucumin
foi
administrado embora esses resultados
devam ser considerados de maneira
cuidadosa né devido ao tamanho da
amostra e a localização geográfica então
em resumo estudo sugere que a
suplementação com curcumina dessa desse
tipo de auto absorção junto ao
tratamento padrão parece que melhorou os
resultados de sintomas da covid no
entanto é importante notar que a cocoma
não foi testada de forma isolada e
portanto eh os pesquisadores não podem
atribuir a ele toda a melhoria observada
além disso a composição do grupo de
participantes incluindo o estatus de
vacinação e a necessidade de um número
maior de participantes para análise
estatisticamente mais robustas são
pontos que são considerados ao
interpretar os resultados Boa noite
Roberto Marta e Álvaro então para
finalizar esse estudo nos proporciona
uma visão valiosa sobre o potencial da
cucumina como coadjuvante no tratamento
de covid-19 destacando a importância de
continuar a pesquisa nessa área para
validar e entender plenamente os
benefícios né então estudo mostrando
claramente uma coisa que a já sabia que
a cucumina tem efeito antiviral
antiinflamatório e é uma boa ideia no
uso do
covid então só Resumindo os efeitos
positivos foi redução de sintomas como
tosse fadiga melhora da saturação de
oxigênio no
sangue o segundo estudo da noite é um
estudo que
mostrou a relação da dieta e a saúde
cardíaca então frequentemente nos
deparamos com uma questão muito
pertinente que qual que a dieta que
realmente promove a melhor saúde
cardíaca e a resposta a essa complexa
questão
[Música]
eh está relacionada a diversas opções
alimentares
disponíveis destacando-se entre elas a
dieta vegana e a dieta onívora Então
esse estudo de o semanas de duração
buscou lançar luz sobre ess bate então o
design desse estudo foi singular
comparou os efeitos de dietas veganas e
onívoras na saúde
cardiometabólica recrutou 22 pares de
gêmeos idênticos como participantes
então A genética Idêntica dos pares
forneceu um potunidade rara de atribuir
diferenças observadas exclusivamente aos
efeitos das Dietas testadas Então vamos
aos resultados desse estudo comparando a
dieta vegana con
onívora então eles analisaram vários
parâmetros
inclusive peso corporal nível de LDL
colesterol insulina né então os
desfechos eles analisaram a DL
colesterol que nós sabemos que é um
marcador lipídico muito valorizado pelos
cardiologistas também analisar os
efeitos das Dietas sobre o peso corporal
os níveis de
insulina e os
resultados foram reveladores né o grupo
vegano exibiu uma diminuição
significativa do LDL colesterol ao lado
de quedas no peso corporal e nos lives
de insulina Então os três parâmetros
foram melhores no grupo
vegano então houve um perfil
cardiometabólico melhor para esse tipo
de
dieta
então Houve essa questão de usar gêmeos
né então controlando as variações
genéticas usando gêmeos os pesquisadores
foram capazes de isolar o impacto dessas
dietas sobre a saúde dos participantes
oferecendo uma visão mais clara sobre o
efeito de cada padrão alimentar então
eles tiveram o cuidado de balancear as
dietas de maneira controlada com
refeições padronizadas que foram
entregues aos participantes Então as
refeições foram totalmente
controladas proporcionando consistência
e credibilidade aos resultados então nós
sabemos que as doenças cardíacas são uma
das maiores preocupações de saúde no
nosso tempo e diante disso a alimentação
surge como fator crucial na prevenção e
manejo dessas condições Então os dados
desse estudo indicam possíveis
benefícios de uma dieta vegana na
redução de riscos Associados à doenças
cardíacas acrescentando eh valor à
prática clínica nutrici ial fornecendo
diretrizes baseadas em evidências
sólidas mas vamos falar das limitações
desse exame desse estudo a duração foi
relativamente curta né para estudo que
você fornece a comida PR as pessoas
geralmente o estudo é curto Então as
diferenças calóricas entre as duas
dietas também é um fator né porque a
dieta vegana tinha menos calorias isso
pode ter influenciado a perda de peso
então é necessário ter estudos
adicionais para compreender Ender melhor
essa
situação nós sabemos que a ciência da
nutrição é uma das mais difíceis de
interpretar é complicado eu tenho
opiniões diferentes desse estudo mas tô
mostrando aqui para vocês porque é um
estudo de alta
qualidade Então esse estudo Teoricamente
poderia ampliar nosso entendimento sobre
como escolhas alimentares podem
influenciar diretamente a saúde do
coração né então
[Música]
eh diante desses resultados é importante
refletir sobre eles e ver se
realmente a questão aqui foi as calorias
ou se a dieta vegana realmente é
superior tá eu penso que
essa questão aí desse estudo ele deve
ter sido contaminado por outras
situações aí porque eu não acredito que
a carne vermelha ou a carne
branca aumente o risco cardiovascular se
preparados da forma corr correta né sem
você exceder a temperatura e queimar a
superfície da da carne que a gera
aquelas substâncias que são tóxicas como
é o caso os copos de glicação avançada e
as aminas
heterocíclicas então é estudo que
sinceramente apesar de ser de alta
qualidade me deixou meio intrigado e eu
não concordo com os resultados Mas vamos
responder às dúvidas ao vivo
agora
primeira pergunta deixa eu dividir a
tela com vocês
aqui vamos ampliar aqui para ficar mais
fácil de vocês
lerem primeira pergunta é do thgo idosa
de 80 anos P controlado tirando isso
ável duas Heras abdominais pequenas o
médico recomenda operar de imediato
outro diz que para
monitorar sabendo da individualidade de
cada caso porém no caso porém no geral
os riscos de complicações como
encarceramento mesmo quando as hérnias
são pequenas ou o risco de aumentar de
tamanho ainda seria grande Tais riscos
poderiam superar o risco da cirurgia em
si
Olha isso aqui é é uma análise de caso
Clínico não é o objetivo nosso aqui do
canal mas eu vou procurar responder de
uma maneira tá
que te ajude deum de alguma forma apesar
disso aqui não ser o nosso objetivo aqui
do canal tá
é o seguinte vai depender muito da
atividade física Dessa senhora se ela é
muito ativo não é e o quanto que essas
enas evoluíram no tempo se essas enas
não tem há muitos anos estão do mesmo
tamanho há bastante tempo eu não
operaria agora se essas Heras estão
crescendo de tamanho existe o risco sim
de
ccero Então eu acho que o ponto
principal se analisado aqui é se essas
Heras estão crescendo ou não se não
estão crescendo eu não mexeria se elas
tiverem aumentando de tamanho claramente
ao longo do tempo eu faria a cirurgia
sim porque você falou que ela é saudável
O único problema que ela tem aqui é o
paxon que aparentemente é controlado
tá então essa que é o ponto principal A
tá crescendo sim ou não porque aí se não
tiver crescendo Eu acho que o risco da
anestesia até
maior do que o risco da n em si da
anestesia e da cirurgia em si
né próximo Tiago sobre o vídeo da
glutamina visto que câncer pode ser
muitas vezes silencioso principalmente
em seus estádios iniciais seria melhor
fazer exames antes de tomar ou risco
maior seria para pessoas e já em
estágios avançados eu não acho thago que
seja um problema você usar Glutamina se
você não tem nenhum diagnóstico de de
câncer não e mesmo que você possa ter um
câncer silencioso a glutam Não é esse
veneno todo que o l Ribeiro deixou a
entender tá até porque essa história do
tumor só se alimenta de glicose e de
aminoácidos que viram glicose não é
verdade tem tumor que consegue se
alimentar tá assim de Aços gros faz beta
oxidação só que eu não vou falar isso em
vídeo abertamente porque vai gerar
estresse aí vai gerar problema com muita
gente
que não vai entender a o recado então eu
tô falando para vocês que do grupo
fechado eu acho que essa história da
glutamina alcançou
uma um tamanho exagerado eh não é assim
a Glutamina não vai gerar câncer você
tiver um câncer oculto não vai ser a
Glutamina que vai te ferrar tá bom acho
que você não tá ao vivo Thiago depois
você vai ter que assistir o vídeo né a
versão
gravada Castanha de Caju o senhor disse
um vídeo que ela não é boa se comer crua
as opções torradas geralmente são
torradas com óleos vegetais torrar elas
no forno de casa seria a melhor opção
sem dúvida
né
isso não saturar o óleo natural dela não
entendi essa história de saturar o óleo
dela não entendi você fala que o calor
vai saturar o óleo
dela não o que satura e gordura saturada
não tem é assim ela pode ser saturada ou
poliinsaturada ou monoinsaturada não é o
calor que determina ser saturada ou
insaturada é a própria gordura em si tá
não sei se você entendeu esse conceito
de saturação é a quantidade que tem de
hidrogênio na na molécula de de gordura
né se você tem muita ligação Dupla ela é
insaturada e tem menos hidrogênio tá
então as gorduras saturadas geralmente
elas são bem estáveis no calor elas não
estragam por o óleo de coco tá cheio de
gordura só tem gordura saturada ali e
ela é bem estável Ela não estraga quando
você aquece na
panela tá bom seria bom se tá aoo vivo
que a gente poderia trocar ideia aqui
melhor
[Música]
né Marta Perez deixa eu ver se a Marta
Perez está tá ela tá ao vivo Qual a sua
opinião sobre o uso tópico de gel
contendo 20% de dmso 2,5 de clofenac 2,5
de Nimesulida para massagem no joelho eu
acho ótimo porque o DMS vai aumentar a
absorção do Diclofenaco da nimesulida e
ela vai ficar localizado e não vai dar
efeito sistêmico né se você tomar o
clofenac e murite pode dar dor de
estômago pode dar lesão renal pode dar
problema de intestino pode dar problema
em vários órgãos então utópico é bem
melhor eu acho uma boa
ideia essa estratégia aí tá agora eu
monitorar aí a função renal para ver se
essa quantidade de antiinflamatório que
tá entrando no joelho não tá ganhando a
a corrente
sanguínea certo Marta se você está ao
vivo a hora que eu tô vendo se você
quiser responder se você entendeu se
você tem mais alguma
pergunta Silva colonoscopia mais
abrangente que
endoscopia As duas são endoscopias tá a
diferença que existe endoscopia
digestiva alta e digestiva baixa a
adjetiva baixa a gente chama de
colonoscopia e a alta tem esse nome
endoscopia adjetiva alta Ok então os
dois exames são exames de eh de imagem
não seia se se seria o termo são exames
que você coloca a câmera e faz gravação
né do trato tanto digestivo quanto
do da questão do Colon né do reto do
Colon tá abrangente aqui não sei se a
palavra mais eh correta na verdade a
colonoscópio ele é mais comprido que o
endoscópio então ele ele tem uma
distância maior que ele
percorre certo enquanto com endoscopia
digestiva geralmente você Verê só
esôfago estômago e no e a primeira
porção do duodeno você não vai pra
segunda porção nem pra terceira porção
do duodeno então em termos de distância
a colonoscopia é uma distância
maior certo não sei se se era essa sua
dúvida porque ficou um pouco confuso
aqui a colonoscopia dá uma ideia médico
Desculpa tô com uma garganta meio
irritada
hoje a colonoscopia da uma ideia médico
se é necessária uma endoscopia não
totalmente diferente estão vendo
territórios diferentes então não não o
fato de ter feita a
colonoscopia não
vai evitar de fazer uma endoscopia ou
vice-versa tem que ver pelos sintomas e
indicação Clínica não porque fez
colonoscopia primeiro ou vice-versa
Eliseu eh Live eliz eu não sei acho que
eu não vou fazer Live eu tô com uns
projetos pessoais essa semana que tá me
tomando muito tempo eu não tô com cabeça
pra Live essa semana não acho que eu não
vou fazer Live essa semana não vou
deixar PR semana que vem
tá
Eliseu quem quiser participar de uma
maratona cognitiva intensiva pode tomar
todos os suplementos aqui tudo junto
juba de leão LT anina bacopa fosfa di
cerina B12 cavac
101 ômega-3 creatina magnésio Azul metil
pode pode tomar tudo junto não vejo
problema nenhum eu tenho muitos
pacientes aí com alheimer que tomam
muito mais do que isso Inclusive tem
tomar mais suplementos do que
isso Eliseu nos hoje metir 2 graus de
Pureza sim eu só usaria o SP que é o
grau farmacêutico tá o SP mais ou menos
95% não é 99,9 uma coisa assim o pa é
para análise tá vai ter menos vai ter
mais do que o grau SP que é
Farmacêutico Silva uma pessoa que tem
vitamina D de 38 poderia indicar uma
suplementação de vitamina D e c vân como
K2 sim o ideal se manter Entre 50 e 70
no sangue Tá bom então se tá 38 eu
tomaria 5.000 por dia e veria como é que
se comporta isso se não aumentar
significativamente aumentaria para
10.000 por
dia Eliseu lá no YouTube Diz que a dose
de azul de metileno na concentração de
1% é de duas
gotas para pessoas de 45 a 50 4 gotas
pessoas de 90 a 100 e três gotas para
pessoas de 75 se for na concentração de
5% para 70 kg são quantas gotas tem que
fazer fazer uma regrinha de três ô elizu
Isso aqui é uma conta matemática se for
na conação Ah todas essas perguntas suas
são matemáticas se você quiser
eh faz as contas você mesmo tá faz a
regra de três para você ver a a questão
tá em média tá eu passo entre 20 MG a 50
mg de azul de metileno eh para adultos
tá só para te dar uma ideia disso
aí
pío É bom sim é ótimo contraindicações
algumas pessoas que TM intestino
irritável for muito gases com psílio e
sentem distendidas tá essa que seria a
contraindicação básica que Marc Eu
recomendo Geralmente eu passo pilo
manipulado eu não tô com nenhuma marca
na cabeça aqui não para te
falar Geralmente eu passo
manipulado Luciana gostaria de saber se
cloreto de magnésio algum outro tip
magnésio prejudicial aos rins só se for
em excesso né Magnésio e excesso pode
ser prejudicial aos rins Sim ok Mas se
você tomar na dose correta não vai ser
de forma
alguma Isaac Quantas colheres de TCM é
ideal para um bom rendimento cerebral
depende eh você pode começar com uma
colher de sobremesa por dia e aumentar
até tomar uma colher de sopa ou duas
colheres de sopa por dia tem gente que
tem diarreia e tem gente que fica
agitada com TCM Então você vai
aumentando aos
pouquinhos
R Elita Teria algum tratamento natural
eficaz para eczema
crônico tem que tentar identificar a
causa desse equizema se é alimentar ou
se é demate de contato fazer um teste de
intolerância alimentar ou teste pric
teste aqueles testes que você faz na
pele para identificar alérgenos de
pele e vai depender eh para exema eu
usaria ldn na altona de baixa
dosagem alguns pacientes respondem bem a
vitamina D em altas doses né o protocolo
Coimbra eu acho seria basicamente essas
três coisas identificar o agente
agressor vitamina D em altas doses e o
ldn que é o louos nax Né not baixa
daade bem boa noite quem não dei boa
noite
ainda Carlos já dei né Marta perz acho
Eliseu já dei boa noite já dei Adriana
boa noiteo vamos responder as dúvidas ao
vivo agora
aqui se eu tenho um curso online para
terapeutas eu tô lançando em breve
Adriana tá pronto curso mas eu tô vendo
as estratégias aí de campanha de
marketing um curso
de
terapia próstata com substâncias
naturais tá então a mistura de
fitoterapia com otom molecular eu também
falo tratamento convencional nesse nesse
curso compara o convencional com esse
tratamento com fitoterápicos e autom
moleculares tá então eu vou lançar em
breve esse curso já tá disponível lá no
hotmart Mas eu ainda não tô
divulgando Tiago valeu pelas respostas
de nada pois é falei saturação mas a
ideia era saber se acontece com as anhas
o mesmo que acontece quando aquece o
azeite de oliva não não porque o óleo da
da castanha ela é saturada não é não é
insaturado
não não vai acontecer a mesma coisa a de
oliva é mono insaturado e mesmo assim eu
uso para frituras rápidas o azeite de
oliva porque ele não degrada tanto
quanto foi falado no passado já vi os
três estudos falando que ele é um óleo
que dá para fazer fritura assim tá ele
não é po insaturado ele é
monoinsaturado então ele não degrada
tanto a não ser que seja uma gordura de
imersão agora a os olhos das castanhas
vou até checar isso agora eles são
saturados
[Música]
tá só tô checando aqui junto uma
inteligência artificial que eu tenho
aqui de
[Música]
artigos
para confirmar essa informação
contigo bem realmente eh você tem tem
razão o principal óleo da castanha São
insaturados não são não são saturados
não
vou checar a questão da deteriorização
desses olhos com altas
temperaturas
ah
eu tô checando aqui a questão do
aquecimento dos olhos porque a fonte que
eu tô conferindo tá dizendo que tem
deterioração dos horas Qual temperatura
sim então o ponto aí que a c de Caju tem
toxina que tem que ser aquecida para
anular essa toxina por isso não pode
comer
cru então o aquecimento tem que ser
feito de maneira controlada e uniforme
não pode passar de uma certa
temperatura então o processo de torragem
tem que ser bastante lento e
uniforme tá então a questão aí são as
toxinas naturais da da castanha de caju
Então tem que fazer sim o aquecimento
Mas vai ter uma certa deteriora a dos
olhos sim tá essa que é a resposta mais
correta
ah Dr Alan volta por favor na pergunta
11 do formulário para responder as
perguntas CD e
e El eu teria que fazer cálculo para
poder responder isso tá eu não tô não
vou fazer isso agora porque vai tomar
tempo tá bom eu acho mais fácil você
mandar manipular Liu de 30 mg e toma de
30 mg essa a dose padrão que eu uso tá e
pode ser aumentado em algumas
circunstâncias
eu acho que não tem muito sentido você
fazer esse monte de cálculo aí eu não
vou fazer isso ao vivo agora porque vai
tomar tempo e vai eu vou ficar calado
fazendo um conta matemática aqui
tá mais perguntas
pessoal
eh dottor vai vai divulgar o curso no
grupo mas acredito que seja muito
avançado e nós não teríamos condições de
fazer eu tentei fazer da maneira
equilibrada Adriana não deixei tão
difícil não tá eu deixei de uma maneira
que é acessível para nutricionista para
terapeuta caso você tenha interesse
nesse assunto Tá de tratamento de
próstata Qual é a quantidade de TCM que
podemos gerir por dia para extrair o
máximo benefício vai depender como eu
falei começa usando uma colher de
sobremesa vê como é que é a sua reação
se você não tiver nenhum problema de
agitação ou diarreia aumenta por uma
colher de sopa fica um tempo tomando uma
colher de sopa e depois você Experimenta
tomar uma colher de sopa de manhã e uma
à
noite
certo
mais perguntas pessoal essa essa
pergunta do do azul de metileno como eu
te expliquei o tem que fazer conta
Eliseu tá eu não tem como responder isso
agora porque vou ter que para ficar
fazendo continha aqui né não faz muito
sentido Não é esse o propósito propósito
aqui do grupo
tá Boa noite Fernanda seja bem-vinda
mais perguntas
pessoal porque veja bem elizu só para
você achar que eu não tô de má vontade ó
ó 1% é 10 mg por ml 5% são 5 mg por ml
então se você mesmo colocou aqui três
gotas para pessoa de 75 kg
né na concentração de 1% é regra de TR
sim como não é
reg certo é tudo questão de concentração
aqui você fazer os ajustes
0% é 1 MG por
ml tá então isso isso são são ajustes
são contas não é uma coisa para né ficar
respondendo aqui na live nó Vamos
responder outra pergunta sua aqui é
verdade que Israel é o único país que
possui trigo
não modificado sem
glúten tá então você está perguntando
aqui da pergunta CDE tá concentração de
5% recomenda também recomendo a questão
não é concentração é a dose em
miligramas azul de metileno com 0,1 de
concentração é mais puro que o grau SP
não tem nada a ver com a com a
concentração o grau de de Pureza é uma
coisa concentração é outra azul de
metino 0% mais pur não não tem nada a
ver Eliseu é mesma coisa você falar
assim
eh substância A 0,11% é mais pura que a
substância A 5% não el não é isso que
vai comparar não é a concentração você
tem que comparar é o grau de Pureza não
é a
concentração vamos voltar pra pergunta
do Trigo eu não não sei ess responder
essa sua pergunta Israel o único país
que possui trigo saudável não tem vários
países do mundo que tem trigo sarraceno
que é um trigo árabe que não tem glúten
tá não é Israel deve ter mas tem vários
outros países do mundo que que tem
também
tá É verdade que tem farmácia e
manipulação muito mais confiáveis do que
os suplementos que você compra lá
fora depende da farmácia depende do do
lugar onde você compra os suplementos
tem eh compan suplementos aí que são
muito bo
e tem uns que são ruins e tem
manipulações boas e ruins Então tem que
ver de qual manipulação
falando de
qual empresa suplement está
falando oo sublingual de suplemento B12
da Ger possui sabor a substância que
provoca sabor eu suspeito seja
química quebra o jejum não não quebra
não
aproveitando a pergunta do Eliseu sobre
os
glut
Desculpa me disseram que na Europa eles
conseguem inclusive Faria de trigo sem
glutem sim a Faria de trigo da Europa é
melhor sim é mais
saudável fale um pouco sobre um sintoma
que eu tenho que folga itard descer tipo
5 horas da tarde não sei o que faz faz
para melhorar isso
e provavelmente tá relacionado ao seu
sono e tá relacionado ao seu stress tá
tem que analisar se seu sono tá de
qualidade fazer uma
polissonografia checar se você tá
dormindo no horário correto se você tá
fazendo higi do sono
e chegar seu livro de estresse fazer uma
meditação e passar em consulta né para
avaliar outros parâmetros
aí
creatina tomar de manhã bloqueia o
crescimento do GH não não bloqueia
não
eh essa pergunta aqui é do do glúten né
eu tenho certeza que a farinha da Europa
é melhor mas ela contém glúten sim mas
ela de melhor qualidade dá menos reação
que a farinha dos Estados Unidos do
Brasil com as mudanças de temperatura
que estão para vir Quais são os cuidados
que devemos
tomar então Boa pergunta eu nunca li
nada a respeito de suplemento para
oscilação de temperatura eu acho que tem
cuidar o sistema imune principalmente né
com vitamina
D O principal porque você vai se
proteger contra infecções que podem
acontecer quando você tem oscilação de
temperatura e e tem vários compostos que
ajudam no sistema imune né então tem tem
vários aí que e que cetina
Glutamina você tem aí o o extrato de de
alguns cogumelos né que tem são ricos aí
em substâncias que vão proporcionar um
melhor do sistema imune então tem uma
série de suplementos aí tem vários
vídeos no canal falando sobre isso sobre
suplementos para sistema imune tá Dá uma
olhada nesses vídeos eu acho que seria
esse os a a os
principais como não tenho controle sobre
maneira de vendedor torra Castanha não é
melhor comer castanha de caju crua não
eu expliquei isso agora a pouco ela tem
uma substância tóxica tá
eh que não vai ser inibida ou anulada
com suplemento ou alimento antioxidante
isso não não é uma coisa válida Não
Dizer de nada
Adriana
bem pessoal acho que tá bom né não tem
mais perguntas eu vou esperar mais 5
minutinhos tá paraa gente poder
[Música]
encerrar
tem mais uma pergunta aqui no YouTube
você disz para comer quentro três vezes
semana pelo menos pensei que isso fosse
também eliminar as
toxinas não não creio que vai eliminar
não Eliseu as toxinas da castan de
Caju Obrigado Adriana pelos comentários
boa noite para você
também mais perguntas
pessoal bem então vou encerrar aqui viu
ah não tem um comentário do verer aqui
sim Doutor tenho muito estresse Devido
ao trabalho muito cansaço tomo suo para
mitocôndrias que melhora os sintomas Tem
que rever se estresse seu o é uma coisa
temporária Tem como melhorar
isso excesso trabalho o que que é
entendeu se for uma coisa temporária
tudo bem mas se for uma coisa permanente
vai te fazer mal paraa tua saúde isso
daí
né
Certo muito obrigado pessoal pela
participação de vocês Desculpa pelas
tosses pelas falhas nós no vemos na
próxima semana um abraço
n